[Music]
let's go to uh brad in st louis missouri
what's up brad
hello john
what's up man hey thanks for so much for
taking my call of course thanks for
calling what's up dude
uh i got a situation in life i'm looking
to get some advice on uh how to move
forward with it okay um
i've
struggled with social anxiety for years
and now oh man recently
recently i went through uh
i'm just kind of emerging out of a kind
of a dark hole depression and social
anxiety
all right
what the situation was i had a i had a
a construction company
and it totally
the the social part of it kind of wiped
me out
and
i i had to sell my business and i got
out of it and i've been kind of
recuperating for the last few few months
here i've had enough money to be able to
do that okay
but
i'm wondering how to move forward now
i'm wondering if i should be you know i
need to find a job at some point so i
have to get something going here
yeah how long have you struggled with
social anxiety
i think it's been it's been since my
childhood okay is your heartbeat is your
heart beating pretty fast on this call
it is yeah yeah so i will stop and say
you're a brave guy okay yeah if people
have never struggled with uh social
anxiety before just imagine walking up
on stage buck naked and then waving with
both hands right that's what it feels
like just to go have a normal
conversation right
it does yeah so tell me um i want to
challenge you i'm a fellow anxiety guy
myself okay so is it okay if i push on
you a little bit
yep for sure
you said you had to sell your business i
don't believe that convince me why'd you
have to sell it
i guess i made that choice to sell it
look at that dude you're already better
okay so why did you choose to sell it
i just had so much anxiety dealing with
people that that i
basically felt like i couldn't like like
you said my heart was dumping out of my
chest every time i went to
talk to somebody or visit with somebody
or deal with one of my employees okay
so
basically i didn't have the mental
capacity at that point to deal with
anything
um were you the owner operator of the
company
yes i was
so
two of my first jobs
in
the university settings
were because my bosses were brilliant
and very
strategic thinkers great writers
they did not like public speaking
and that's why they hired me
they hired their
their the parts that were challenging
for them they would have been very
uncomfortable with all the public
speaking that goes into a lot of those
public-facing jobs so they hired me that
was my job and i had to learn how to do
budgets on the back end so my question
to you is
what kept you from keeping your business
and hiring somebody that would
help do the things that you didn't like
doing or didn't feel comfortable doing
um
even the thought of even the thought of
that at the at the time was was too much
to handle you know okay
i i basically kind of
tried to do everything myself and i
pushed through i've done it in the past
i've pushed through everything but then
i would i would hit the limit and i
would back so
you know i
i push myself
with
the help of lots of caffeine and maybe
some sugar and just keep going you know
yeah but that can only get me so far you
know that's right
that's a strategy you've used for your
entire life isn't it
yes it is would you be willing to do
something different for the first time
yeah i would okay let me promise you
something okay
um
i had anxiety so bad i couldn't look at
a stock market chart like i would go in
buildings at the university where i
worked at i would go to different
buildings and take different avenues in
because i knew there was a stock ticker
in one of the
um
one of the like the nba classrooms
um i couldn't look at at tv screens
because i never knew if there was going
to be that little ticker underneath it
or the stock market on one side like for
some reason
my brain i was in 2008 2009 it just it
just connected to that i couldn't be in
the room with it and then it got
prohibitive right because i was in these
business meetings we were talking about
the future of the company and all this i
couldn't do it i had to step out of
these meetings or i'd start causing
scene not a scene but i would try to
distract the conversation like and
that's just one of several okay so i'm
telling you that to tell you this
on the back i now work at a finance
company
right
yep like my boss teaches people how to
get out of debt and so
i tell you that there's healing like you
wouldn't believe on the other side
does the idea of sitting with people and
just having a hilarious conversation
um
and dumping water on somebody and being
goofy and having them throw water like
is that is that entire is that like
enticing to you like that'd be so cool
if we could ever do that one day
yeah okay
do you trust me that you can get there
i trust you but i just
trust myself you're like nope nope nope
hey that's cool man hey that's totally
fine you don't have to trust me i'll
prove it to you okay
okay all right here's a couple of things
that you've probably been told us over
time um but i'm going to say them out
loud again
all right and and here's what we'll do
we'll cut this episode and i'll have
them send it to you uh today or tomorrow
and you don't have to wait for it to
come out in in whenever it comes out
okay
okay
number and i want you to have these
things number one
when you have social anxiety avoidance
makes it worse
and you start thinking about
meeting with people and then the machine
spins up right
right yep and then it spins up and now
you're worried about the machine
spinning up you're not even worried
about the people anymore you're pre
worried about the worry right yeah yeah
and then you open the moment the second
you open your eyes your heart starts
beating faster
yeah
is that is that is that your experience
yeah exactly okay and then once that
what happens is that once i get into it
a lot of times it subsides yes yes yes
yes okay
here's the challenge
it's a crazy glitch in the matrix on how
anxiety works all anxiety is is a smoke
alarm in your kitchen okay
that's all it is it's just letting you
know hey we don't think this is safe
and it also goes off when you're lonely
and so if you struggle from social
anxiety it always is going off because
you're lonely or now you're about to be
around people and they're not safe now
we're lonely and so it never stops and
that that what you described perfectly
is i just got to a point where i had to
sell everything and just quit
it's like being in a in a kitchen and
the smoke alarm's going off and it's so
loud and your kids and your wife are
just acting like nothing's wrong and
finally you have to go out in the yard
because it's so loud right
that's what social anxiety is okay
you're not broken you're not deficient
there's just something in your head that
has identified the thought not actually
other people the thought of being with
other people as something that is scary
and gonna hurt us so let's sound the
alarms
and the goal is over time to just teach
your body
hey i hear that i hear the alarm but
it's all good
it's all good
and we're gonna teach our body over time
okay so number one avoidance makes it
worse
number two
curiosity not war
here's what i mean by that
when your alarm set off
if you immediately try to shut them down
to power through to push through to flex
really tight your brain will think oh he
doesn't hear me let's make him louder
versus
the anxiety alarms go off your heart
starts beating faster you wake up and
you can hardly drink your coffee
and then you get curious why is my body
trying to keep me alive there's nobody
coming at me with a hatchet what's the
deal here
oh i got these two meetings today
i love
dan and jim
and there's going to be one
uncomfortable conversation i'm going to
have bill do that i don't want to talk
to that guy
or i'm going to fire this guy and it's
going to be really uncomfortable for me
so i'm going to write this one down
because this one's going to hard this
one's going to not be fun you see what
i'm doing there i'm being curious with
my body not getting mad at it i'm not
because when you get mad at it then you
start pre-worrying about the worry that
you're gonna have about the anxiety that
comes later
see what i'm saying yep here's the main
way to say that stay out of your head
do you keep something with you you can
write down
i don't no no i haven't okay i'm holding
this up if you see us on the youtube
channel
you can laugh at me all you want and i
wish i had a cooler name for this i put
cool stickers like yeti and like b
wilder and like uh
goruck stickers and stuff on it because
i'm trying to make myself feel tougher
you know what this is like if i really
am just honest with it
this is a uh stories journal a thoughts
journal
and anytime my body starts to take off
on me i just write it down real quick
that's it
and i got it for nine bucks at walmart
i might make one one day that's like 40
and make it all nice and leathery um
but really i just keep it with me at all
times in my backpack
and i keep it out here when i'm doing
shows right here i might think of
something
like you really sucked at that answer
i'll write that down real quick and
here's what i'm doing i'm getting it out
of my body i'm staying out of my head
yeah
okay here's the third word i want to
give you
practice
here's what i mean by that
you got to stop worrying
and worry is an addiction
and here's what i mean
have you ever sat in the shower and had
an imaginary conversation with somebody
that you will never have in real life
yeah
do you ever are you ever driving and you
start rehearsing
conversations you're going to have with
employees of people and other
contractors and your kids and whatever
yeah or called with you
yeah how many times did you rehearse
this call
oh probably 20 times in the last 10
minutes before i was on the phone with
you so okay just listening to you talk
right now your voice is different
because you're smiling your shoulders
are dropped
i can hear your shoulders down as crazy
as that sounds
what you thought was going to happen
didn't happen
is what you think is going to happen
does it ever happen
um
maybe a few times and did you live
oh yeah i survived it ta-da way to go
dude you already
you see
right okay so here's what we're going to
do
i read your book okay i read your book
about the about the backpack
okay
and one of the backpacks that it feels
like i'm carrying is is
that
i won't have
the right words to say to people
i'm kind of a quiet guy
and a lot of times when i'm going into a
situation that's a lot of times what
is preventing me from succeeding it
feels like is that backpack
okay and here's what's going on
100 promise you're not always gonna have
the right words to say
yeah and when i found um going into
homes and telling mothers that their
babies had died or that their sons had
taken their own lives
that the fewer words are often the
better
and so here's a i actually if you go
back on youtube and look at the like the
trailer for this show
one of the calls that i made sure we put
in there was me saying i don't know the
answer to this one i've never heard this
before and i'm laughing
because my identity is not tied in
always having the right things to say
my identity is tied in
sitting with people when they're
struggling
you see the difference
right and so what i want you to practice
is not ha not worrying about having the
right things to say because you're never
gonna have the right things to say
so here's a fun exercise i want you to
do this afternoon once you get a cinder
block
okay
and i want you to put a piece of masking
tape on it and i want you to get a magic
marker and write on the magic on that
cinder block
always having the right thing to say and
i want you to carry it around your house
for 10 or 15 or 20 minutes i'm serious
it's going to be it's going to suck
you're going to your arm is going to be
burning you have to pass it from one
hand to the next
okay set a timer for 15 to 20 minutes
and then at some point you're gonna have
to decide i don't care to have the right
things to say anymore
and then i want you to take it out in
the backyard and i want you to drop it
and never pick it up again
and here's what practice means the
moment that worry lightning bolts into
your head
i'm not going to know what to say
oh that's when you interrupt the thought
that's when you stop the worry and you
say i don't have to worry but i don't
have to have everything to say
i don't have to have anything to say
right now because i'm freaking brad from
st louis
yep i do
and then you're gonna go into a
situation and hey you're gonna know a
lot more to say than you think you do
and on those moments when you don't know
what to say you can say the words i
don't know what to say right now i'm not
to get back with you on that i need a
day to think about this
and that's what you're going to practice
and you're going to practice and you're
going to practice until your body
doesn't sound the alarms your body
begins to know oh brad's got this he's
driving
he sees that big bear at the front of
the cave he sees that tiger in the field
we don't have to sell the alarm he sees
it we're good
now we just have to run or we have to
fight it see what i'm saying
yeah i do yeah okay avoidance makes it
worse the one thing about anxiety is you
got to lean into the you got to lean
into it
okay yeah that's the scary part it is it
is you won't die
you will okay
anxiety won't kill you
running from it might okay yeah
you got to be curious and not go to war
with your body ask yourself why why am i
so worried about this
and number three
don't worry stop worrying and practice
not worrying practice interrupting that
thought pattern
okay i want you to stay on the line i'm
going to send you um i'm going to here's
something i'm going to send you three
copies of redefining anxiety it's a book
i wrote before
um oh and your past change of future and
i want you to read one i want your wife
to read one and if you got kids
aged 15 or older i want them to read it
and it's going to give your family a
common language that y'all could talk
about at home
here's another thing that's unpopular
and i don't care
it might be brad that you go sit down
with a psychiatrist and
for a season anxiety meds helped me
and again if you listen to show a lot
i'm not a guy who goes to meds first i'm
just not
but meds were helpful in turning the
alarm volume down for me so that i could
practice some of these things
and if you've been struggling with this
since you were a little kid that might
help and let your doctor know i let my
doctor know when i walked in the door
i'm not going to put a pill in my mouth
until i have a plan for us to get off
this
and my doctor was like awesome
and we worked together and it's been it
was fantastic
the pill didn't solve the problem
it just helped me be able to create an
environment where i could go get the
help that i needed and it was awesome i
got to talk to a counselor i got some
great friends i started exercising i
started practicing these things i'm
talking about here started leaning into
the discomfort
and the healing on the back end is
something you can't even imagine brad
just gotta trust me it's worth it gotta
trust me that it's worth it and i'll
tell you from
the countless people who've written me
up from all over the country
leaning into anxiety and changing your
thoughts
really working on it
can happen
and and there's peace on the other end
of this deal
so proud of you brad for making the call
so proud of you man
rehearsing tragedy is a waste of your
time
laughter enjoy and connection are not
so let's practice and we'll get there